to some degree i suspect you're not very  agreeable so that's the thing success  for women i'm not very agreeable right  i've noticed that actually it's in  confrontation at least and i'm sure it's  served your career well successful women  though  basically have to wear the trousers in  your view they have to sort of become  men to succeed is what you're saying  well if they're going to i've had to  fight to succeed therefore  certainly masculine traits are going to  be helpful i mean one of the things i do  in in my counseling practice for example  when i'm consulting with women who are  trying to advance their careers is to  teach them how to negotiate and to and  to be able to say no and to not be  easily pushed around and to be  formidable and you need to if you're  going to be successful you need to be  smart conscientious and tough